you were working here in PV
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this video is the second episode of a
new series based on my book new thinking
which is basically the grand history of
science and technology from the
Industrial Revolution till today
[Music]
this story is about something I find
pretty interesting
it's about gary kildall the man who
should have been Bill Gates it's an
absolutely fascinating story and I think
that more people should know about it
the air is 1977 and Apple had just
become extremely successful with their
first PC the Apple 2 it was the first
mass production personal computer that
you didn't have to assemble yourself JB
you wanted to know why I'm doing better
than all the other managers it's no
secret I have an apple sure there's a
big computer three flights down but I
won't test my options do my charts or
edit my reports like my Apple for words
like that or you can move whole
paragraphs around to any where you want
them it's amazing you can use the very
same Apple to do a zillion other things
you could say that the Apple is mightier
than the pan the person will computer PC
industry was already with 1 billion
dollars just three years after it had
become for the first time computers
amplified productivity and human
intellect from within the home IBM who
was in the corporate computer business
of selling large mainframes just saw the
dollar signs this was the opportunity of
all opportunities by 1980 IBM had turned
their attention to Apple success in the
PC market and realized that they were
wrong about the PC it wasn't just a
hobbyist toy anymore it could actually
be useful the problem for IBM is that
they were a huge company though a
bureaucratic and very slow when it came
to decisions it was going to take years
for them just to come up with a PC
design so how were they going to compete
in a timely manner the answer came in
the form of a secret small team within
the company this small team was assigned
the task to create a business orientated
personal computer when they got to work
the decision was made to use
off-the-shelf parts to speed up the
design process using non IBM passes very
unusual for the company with this method
instead of building a computer from
scratch they managed to have a complete
product within a year in 1980 IBM had
the PC hardware cobbled together the
only thing needed was software to run
honor what IBM needed was an operating
system
an operating system is like a computer's
digital traffic cop it keeps track of
how files are stored and how the
computer handles hardware such as a
mouse screen floppy disk drive and etc
basically is the basis that allows for a
modern computer to run at this point
this is where the story starts heating
up IBM was the biggest tech company of
the time so any PC that they made would
have an incredible impact on the world
so what software was going to run on it
this was the battle for one operating
system that would rule them all the
stakes are high every decision here
impacts the rest of our history and
herein lies one of the saddest stories
in computing history while building
their PC in 1980 IBM approached
Microsoft to build the operating system
before saying a word about the project
IBM asked Bill Gates who was initially
mistaken for the office intern to sign a
nondisclosure agreement
Bill Gates had to keep IBM's plan a
secret and he couldn't tell a single
soul when IBM told gates what they were
doing he remarked the Microsoft didn't
have an operating system the 25 year old
programmer would point IBM in the
direction of gary kildall gary was a
meek and mild mannered man but despite
being unassuming he had already paved
the way for operating systems and
personal computers in 1971 kildall had
made a programming language for Intel's
first CPU the 4004 but he quickly
realized that there had to be a way to
control how the chip interacted with the
rest of the computer system in 1972 he
solved this problem with CPM which
stands for control program for micro
computers
this was the very first PC operating
system before CPM each computer had to
have tailor-made software imagine it
like this it would be like having
different types of fuel for every single
car model in existence with an operating
system like CPM a programmer only needed
to write software just once and CPM
would take care of the rest it was a way
to run the very same software on
different computers it just was a very
natural thing to write it turns out
people have a need for an operating
system like that and so uh it was a very
natural thing I wrote it for my own use
despite this Gary didn't really have
much interest in business matters and
was just doing this as a hobby but his
wife Dorothy convinced him to start a
business and start licensing his
creation the result was a company called
digital research by 1979 digital
research became the industry standard
for operating systems in essence they
were the Microsoft of the late 1970s and
Gary was equivalent to Bill Gates so IBM
had just approached Bill Gates and asked
him if he could make an operating system
for their new PC and Bill Gates pointed
them in the direction of Gary so keen to
waste no time
IBM takes bill's advice and pays a visit
to Gary in Seattle bill calls Gary on
the phone to give him some warning that
someone is coming to visit because of
the non-disclosure agreement Gates
couldn't reveal exactly who was coming
to visit bill exclaimed quote treat them
right they're important guys and quote
unfortunately Gary was a somewhat
chilled out guy and didn't really get
the full urgency of what Bill was
warning perhaps he thought it was just
another small company and not the
largest tech company on the planet
because of this Gary isn't home when IBM
visits he's out flying one of his
private planes on business
IBM ends up talking to Gary's wife
Dorothy he was now head of operations in
digital research the lawyers of IBM
began pushing her to sign a
nondisclosure agreement essentially to
say that they were never there Dorothy
wasn't impressed by this and refused to
sign the document the IBM team had a
short temper after going nowhere with
negotiations they became frustrated and
decided to leave Gary's house a few days
later IBM would approach Bill Gates a
second time gates being deterministic
and opportunistic in nature was never
going to give Gary a second chance
he saw that IBM had the potential to
change the PC market into something
entirely different and you cleaned up
business image instead of the geeky
enthusiast image at hat so here comes
the clincher Bill Gates decided to do
something pretty sneaky
he told IBM that Microsoft could in fact
make an operating system even though
they
have one what Microsoft decided to do
was just buy an operating system from a
small company down the road for $75,000
this operating system was called the
quick and dirty operating system or
kudos for sure if you think that that's
a bit of a weird name there's a reason
for it the codis for the software was
essentially a ripoff of CPM the
operating system that Gary had made so
with this ripoff of CPM Microsoft now
had their hands on a functioning
operating system kudos would become
Microsoft DOS or ms-dos for sure and
would be packaged with every IBM PC so
if you've ever used ms-dos it could be
said that you were using the Microsoft
dirty operating system however this name
would be officially changed to Microsoft
disk operating system and of course
ms-dos would eventually become Microsoft
Windows the first IBM PC was released in
August of 1981
it was predicted to make 250,000 sales
but it was a smash hit selling two
million units in a couple of years
IBM had now overtaken Apple as the
world's largest PC manufacturer with
this event it was now truly ok for the
white collar class to get into pcs it
was no longer for hobbyist freaks and
enthusiasts around this time Gary became
the co-host of the show computer
Chronicles a TV program that followed in
detail the progress of personal
computers at the time Gary we're going
to be talking about things like
transportable x' and lap portables but I
want to show you this portable over here
this looks like a pretty small computer
but in fact this is just the keyboard I
can program my things into my computer
and effect this is the computer and of
course it is now a wrist portable now I
don't know whether this does anything
very useful or not in fact that's my
question about this whole subject of
portables is this another case of
Technology in search of a purpose I
don't think so Stuart it's just a new
dimension in technology we have had
faster processors more memory and so
forth in the past now what we're looking
for is trying to get all that speed and
power into a smaller package
so everything was falling into place for
Bill Gates he was getting set to be the
richest man in the world the dirty
operating system was one half of the
equation but some smart business sense
would complete it because the IBM PC was
made from off-the-shelf parts other
manufacturers such as compact an HP
began making their own PC clones
with the very same parts the deal for
Microsoft was that ms-dos would be
licensed to IBM by Microsoft for a
one-time fee of $50,000 but there was a
catch
Microsoft never mentioned to IBM that
their deal was non-exclusive soon
Microsoft was selling ms-dos to all of
IBM's competitors taking a licensing fee
from every computer sold this licensing
deal has been called the greatest deal
in history it made Bill Gates a
billionaire Gary's failure to not be
there at the right time is conversely
called one of the biggest business
failures in history once the sales of
the IBM PC took off
Gary had realized what he had lost for a
rare moment he would shed off his kind
nature and threatened to sue IBM in a
settlement IBM agreed to offer CPM
alongside ms-dos with every PC sold gary
kildall was pleased people could now
choose for themselves which software
they liked best justice had finally been
served there was only just one problem
though when both software packages were
released ms-dos sold for $40 and CPM 240
dollars this was a complete disaster for
almost identical pieces of software for
this reason Garry CPM software would
fade into obscurity in by the late 1980s
Garry had lost to a clone of his own
creation sadly he didn't take a well he
was so crushed by the events that he
didn't ever bother suing Microsoft or
IBM again
the strain from missing out on the
greatest opportunity of many lifetimes
would eventually cause Dorothea to
divorce Gary he would also shy away from
his show the computer chronicles the
ability of personal computers in the
following years meant that Gary would
forever be reminded of his failure
everywhere he turned cured all was slip
into a bout of depression and alcoholism
sadly in 1994 Gary would die from head
injuries in a fistfight at a biker bar
today Gary the man who invented the
operating system for personal computers
is only a faint footnote in technology
history so I think that it's important
that we keep his contribution to the
evolution of computing alive I can see
that it was just a series of unfortunate
events for Gary but if we can take any
lessons away from them it might be make
the most of every opportunity this was
the very first episode of the computer
chronicles broadcast back in 1983 when
we first launched the Siri sitting by my
side as co-host was gary kildall but
gary was a lot more than a TV host Gary
in fact was one of the most important
individuals in the history of personal
computing gary died last year leaving a
legacy not matched by many in this field
that's the end of that story it's pretty
sad night but I thought I'll just um
share it with you cuz it's a pretty
unknown I think a lot of people don't
know that gary kildall and what he did
sir thanks for watching this has been -
go go you're been watching cold fusion
feel free to subscribe if you just
stumble across this channel and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys
[Music]
thinking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]